欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,第十章我们来讲解一下关于产品优化的一个实战系统
这个板块主要是以实操为主
通过从单品优化,爆品流量分析, 以及全店商品提升流量的实战方法
来帮助大家去提升产品的一个转化率
有很多人他其实对产品优化是没有一个结构性的框架的
他不知道去看哪些指标以及去优化哪些维度
对于哪些指标该优化或者是哪些指标不能乱优化
这些他都不是很清楚的
所以就会出现有些时候你会把好的产品
比如说爆品优化了一下然后变成了废品
也就是普通品云盘会很少了
第二种情况就是你把时间和精力放在了很多本不该优化的产品上面
占据了你日常工作的大量的时间
这就导致了你很忙很累
但是却没有结果
你优化的那些动作都是在浪费自己的时间
第三种有很多人去发新品
他就不管不顾了也不去评估数据也不去优化
所以你发的产品就是在等待去看看他有没有潜力的产品起来
但是这种等待会让你浪费非常多的时间
所以这个时候我们应该要怎么样去优化这些新发的产品
一定要提升我们的这些技巧
这个产品优化对我们整个店铺的群盘转化以及自动车的转化都是非常有作用的
我们通过学习这个产品优化的一些框架跟方法
那么我们去分析自动车的时候
他的思路其实是有相关联的
同时呢
我们自动车操作的时候
和判断效果的时候
都是跟这个产品相关的也会关联到产品
新西360这个板块的具体内容
所以这节课是非常重要的
一定要重点去掌握这个产品优化的一个整体的框架
以及哪些指标可以优化
哪些指标不要乱动
那么接下来我们就正式进入课程
我们先来讲第一小节
就是我们要掌握产品的优化逻辑
构建一个完整的优化框架
哪些指标可以优化
哪些指标不需要优化
这些框架我们都要构建起来
第三个就是轻松的去解决我们店铺流量的问题
也就是捉住核心的产品
不要把我们的时间尽力浪费在那些
已经不可能给你带来转变的产品
上面我们这个产品优化的主要目的就是为了获得更多高质量
从而降低直通车的资源浪费
我们要知道优化的核心原理它是什么
它是通过对产品沉淀的数据进行分析
然后找到数据反规差的问题
并把这些问题按照平台规则以及买家的需求以最优的方式去优化解决
从而提升产品的一个是排名
第二个就是提升它的转化效果
那么这里的转化效果就包含一个是点击率
第二个就是寻盘转化率
第三个就是订单转化率
所以说我们这个产品优化的核心原理是非常重要的
我们一定要理解
同时我们要知道通化产品会给我们带来哪些好处
第一个就是点击率可能得到提升
询盘转化率得到提升
订单转化率都会有所提升
第二个就是关于产品优化的数据分析的一个主干线
一定是要遵从这个逻辑的
先是曝光量再到点击量
再到访客再到询盘再到订单量
这一条主线和我们整个店铺的诊断
以及我们直通车的分析跟优化调整
都是均循这一条主干线来进行开展的
也就是都会基于这些维度的指标的数据去衡量和判断它的一个效果
然后再针对对应的指标进行优化的
比如说曝光量到点击量之间
它们之间有一个
动态的衡量标准
指标就是点击率
这是会变的
第2个就是反客量到巡盘量
中间会有一个指标就是巡盘转化率
或者是点击量到巡盘量
这个也是按照一个维度也就是巡盘转化率
点击跟反客分别到巡盘量
的时候的转化率
只是精准度不一样而已
两个维度都可以用这个来衡量
这个就看你怎么样去选择
第3个就是巡盘量到订单量之间
会有一个限量就是
订单转化率
这个就可以衡量我们订单的一个
转化的一个
速度与时间
之间的关系就是按照这个订单转化率来的
所以
你看我们这个
产品优化是不是非常的重要
只要遵循这个路径
那么你就能够
快速的找到问题
并且
针对具体的指标进行一个分析
和进行优化
第3个小点就是精准优化产品
我们将获得三个好处
第1个能够提升我们整个
店铺产品的有效数量
来增加流量的覆盖
第2个就是能够提升
店铺的有效的关键词
总量
也就是有些关键词
虽然在店铺里面
但是
没有任何的曝光点击
所以我们通过优化
可能得到
更多关键词
获取流量
通过优化之后
我们的自然流量精准性更高
第3个就是增加店铺商机总量
也就是我们这里所讲的
提升巡盘的转化率
那么就是巡盘
订单
这些维度都在这个赶快得到提升
所以我们一定要去构建好这个框架
针对性的优化
并且重视
去优化产品
而不是只是发了产品
推广产品从头到尾
都没有去优化过
那么这种情况
会造成大量的资源浪费
所以大家一定要重视起来
开始行动
那么这节课我们就先讲到这里
下一节课我们来讲
具体如何去判断和如何去优化